[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de un cómico en
el estudio rosa feliz mañana de viernes
abrimos entonces esta revista de prensa
vamos a centrarnos en estos 100 días que
se cumplen hoy de la invasión rusa y
ucrania empezamos con la prensa
ucraniana veamos el chief post camiones
zombies con televisiones muestran
propaganda rusa en mayo poll en un
artículo de alexandra christina bueno
esto ya raúl exactamente y solamente la
ilustración que acompaña este titular ya
nos da un indicio muy claro de la tesis
de este artículo fijémonos que sobre una
pantalla aquí en un camión vemos la cara
de vladimir putin sobre el lema no de el
partido de la novela 1984 de george
orwell no el lema de la guerra es paz la
libertad es esclavitud la ignorancia es
fortaleza porque este artículo aborda un
nuevo capítulo de la batalla informativa
el de esta guerra pues ha de ucraniano y
es que recordemos que precisamente
mariupol que es a la ciudad de la que
habla este texto así un escenario muy
evidente de esta batalla por el relato
para mencionar algunos ejemplos
recordemos que cuando esta ciudad
ucraniana fue tomada prácticamente en su
totalidad por las tropas rusas la prensa
oficialista rusa y el kremlin hablaban
de liberación mientras que ucrania
hablaba evidentemente de ocupación por
otro lado cuando finalmente los
combatientes del batallón al
ultranacionalista a soft empezaron a
salirnos de la planta de dos tal pues a
ucrania hablaba de evacuación un término
un poco ambiguo mientras que rusia
hablaba claramente pues de rendición y
finalmente pues este nuevo capítulo como
decimos habla de una estrategia del
ejército ruso que como decíamos ya
controla la ciudad y que ha desplegado
12 pantallas gigantes y 13 y 3 perdón
camiones móviles con pantallas
televisivas a través de la cual pues
retransmite propaganda rusa no por un
lado la periodista nos dice que los
ciudadanos locales los habitantes de
mariupol no sólo tienen que pasar por
campos de filtración una especie de
campos de detención temporal sino que
también tienen que sufrir esta fuerte
propaganda dice en una ciudad en ruinas
y llena de fosas comunes después de los
ataques rusos a través de estas
pantallas a los residentes de mariupol
se les informa sobre las mejoras bajo la
ocupación rusa y los crímenes del
ejército ucraniano bueno pues se dice
que entre otras cosas a través de estas
televisiones se muestran a los testigos
de soldados ucranianos que dicen estar
felices de estar capturados por las
fuerzas rosas raúl pasamos ahora a ver
otro medio ucraniano el iev independent
que abre hoy cómo se tratan estos 100
días de invasión rusa también desde rt
la cadena oficialista rusa exacto muy
rápidamente para repasar algunos
titulares vemos que el kiev independent
en relación a lo que comentábamos no del
quier post está nuevo esfuerzo no de
propaganda dice que según el sinn fein
institute for the studio of war este
think tank estadounidense las fuerzas
rusas tienen dificultades para estable
hacer un control social permanente en
los territorios temporalmente ocupados y
de aquí pues destacar este temporalmente
este adverbio pues que denota un cierto
optimismo no por parte de kiev
independent porque precisamente en otro
titular en otro artículo defiende este
medio de comunicación ucraniano que el
armamento pesado occidental puede marcar
la diferencia en ucrania no solamente
neutralizar la ofensiva rusa sino
también representar un punto de
inflexión en la contraofensiva ucraniana
mientras que rt no está pues cadena tan
partidaria no desde el punto de vista
del cree me dice que no confía en que se
lentes que no use las armas que le
entrega a eeuu para atacar objetivos en
rusia dice que es el entes que promete
muchas cosas y no cumple pues a la
mayoría como que prometió la paz en el
donbass en su campaña electoral que algo
que finalmente no ha cumplido pero
recordemos que rusia también estuvo
semanas insistiendo en que no iba a
invadir ucrania que todo era histeria
occidental bueno y finalmente el 24 de
febrero empezó esta invasión
una imagen que daba la vuelta al mundo
la familia real británica celebrando el
balcón del palacio booking el primer día
este jubileo de platino de la reina
isabel segunda que la memoria y
lanzándose para acá ya se lanzaría para
calles como ella por supuesto y bueno
exactamente esta imagen de ayer ha dado
pues la vuelta a muchos medios de
comunicación internacionales hemos
destacado algunos como el frankfurter
allgemeiner que titula mucho ruido sobre
todo un juego de palabras en relación a
la parafernalia no de este jubileo pero
también a esta imagen que ha sido muy
comentada del príncipe louis recordemos
es el bisnieto de isabel segunda el
quinto en la línea de sucesión que se
tapaba las orejas pues porque no podía
aguantar este ruido de los aviones no
que participaban en esta ceremonia
también destacan la imagen del país de
españa y la nación de argentina con un
cuadro un poco más abierto y finalmente
el wall street journal este medio pues
económico en general también destaca
esta foto pero la compara con para la
imagen de ayer con la del 2 de junio de
1900 53 cuando isabel segunda con su
familia salió también a saludar desde el
balcón del palacio de buckingham tras su
coronación